quand en fin d'après midi devant l'hôtel
matignon manifestation contre la remise
en cause du service public et pour une
télé l'union après la manifestation a
été signée diverses personnalités des
arts et du spectacle
on vous en voici quelques-unes bernard
giraudeau genthod brialy yc morlaix
françois perdre il faut ajouter sur ce
chapitre que l'hebdomadaire la vie
française estime à 10,87 milliards de
francs tf1 et puis un autre hebdomadaire
l'autre journal a décidé de se mobiliser
après télérama et l'événement du jeudi
contre la privatisation de tf1 autres
manifestations après celles ci devant
l'hôtel matignon ce sera samedi à paris
place de la